polarized sunglasses are really good at
blocking glare it all has to do with the
orientation of the filter in your
glasses to understand how that works we
need to look at these a little closer
super zoom a polarizing material is
typically made of long chains of atoms
or molecules they're strongly bonded
along One Direction and Loosely bonded
along the other if a light wave enters
its vibration is absorbed along the
strong molecule chains as a result the
outgoing wave is aligned perpendicular
to those chains the Loosely bonded
direction that perpendicular direction
is the axis of the polarizer that means
every polarized lens has an axis these
axes are vertical they block all
horizontal glare which is most glare
unfortunately if you're getting glare
off the side of a building you're out of
luck unless you tilt your head sideways
but that could get uncomfortable real
fast the point is